so what are they going to do take the
pyramid send Cleopatra's Needle down
pass that every day knowing the history
of it only check the statues so happy to
see that the statue of calm down once
the statue has come down what do you do
next
if in fact the social conditions are
made the same
[Music]
[Applause]
what I'm concerned about is in a hundred
years you look back and somebody said
who was goostin
I think removing history is one should
consider it carefully my initial
reaction as a black person would like to
see them down but actually I think that
this is not a good idea
if we just remove them people will think
that this is the end of racism
discrimination and all these things and
all these things will carry out just it
just seems wrong within the 21st century
I have to pass Brixton library and see a
bus this man who accumulated his vast
wealth from so much misery so much death
statues the things that so many of us
just walk past in the street we just
ignore them apart from if you're
somebody who feels that they represent
something that is fundamentally an
attack on you and who you are
[Music]
as a historian I think it's really
important that we think about the
difference between history and the past
so history is our interpretation of
events it's constantly evolving and
constantly changing and so pulling down
statues is part of that conversation
it's part of looking at these figures
and saying they don't represent us
anymore they don't represent the values
that we want to see celebration our
cities